er kann löffel verbiegen mit der kraft
seiner gedanken angeblich sosa
weltberühmt geworden sie kennen alle uri
geller ja der tv magier mensch der es
inzwischen ein bisschen älter geworden
75 jahre alt der mann aus israel und
jetzt ganz mit was anderem im geschäft
er droht nämlich putin und das meinte
richtig ernst der uri geller der droht
nämlich putin ich werde deine
atomraketen umlenken und zwar hier
wieder mit der kraft meiner gedanken uri
geller der magier der knöpft sich putin
vor mit diesem video zum beispiel
ich habe eine warnung für sie putin ich
fordere sie auf meine warnung zu lesen
sie alle denn ich meine es ernst
er spricht also eine ernste warnung aus
der uri geller und hat gleichzeitig
einen offenen brief noch nachgelegt und
freudigen anschauen in denen auch mal
rein und da sagte dass nämlich auch ganz
genau ich sprechen ernste warnung an sie
aus ich werde jedes aller kleinste
moleküle der kraft meine gedanken
einsetzen um sie daran zu hindern
atomraketen einzusetzen und das meint
der 23 jährige und das schließt diesen
brief mit diesen worten hier ihre
kontroll computer also ihre herr putin
ihre kontroll computer die werden
crashen ihre navigationssysteme die
werden ausfallen ihrer raketen werden
versagen ich habe sie gewarnt uri geller
schauen wir was wir so nicht
funktionieren der super wenn er das
könnte
[Musik]